november danke er allen übernahme ist
sogar herzlich willkommen wir heute zu
einem neuen video auch in einem letzten
video von mir indem ich auf ein video
vor den senioren zocken reagiert habe
gesagt es ist so witzig wenn die auf ein
video von mir reagieren würden dann
reagiere ich wieder auf das video nun
ist es so reagiert schon leute das ist
jetzt passiert das heißt ich würde sagen
wir fangen direkt mal an mit der ersten
szene aus dem video von dem halo luca er
will denn ich heiße luca nicht luca luka
aber wir gucken das video mal weiter und
wenn es übel gekrümmt michael h
evelyn
hi5 let's play mit evelin senioren
zocken deutschlands älteste let's play
rinn und das ist sie genau dieses video
war nämlich das erste video was sich
überhaupt je von den senioren zocken
gesehen habe das war das video will in
gta gezockt habe davon haben die hier
noch mal ein kleiner ausschnitt
eingefügt wie ich überhaupt
kennengelernt habe aber wir schauen uns
weiter an wie die auf mich reagiert
haben ich finde ich oft mal bedanken für
die gewässer was du für uns oder über
uns gemacht hast da muss ich jetzt
ehrlich gesagt sagen das finde ich sehr
sehr schön dass das video von dem kanal
senioren zocken beziehungsweise von den
intervall beziehungsweise von den
senioren selbst positiv aufgenommen
wurde weil meine eltern haben unter
anderem auch das video gesehen und auch
freunde von mir und andere leute und
auch ihr habt ja teilweise gesagt gerade
nicht dass die sagen du machst dich über
die lustig
ich wollte kurz vor kurzem an der stelle
noch mal kurz angefügt dass hier ist
alles auf einer humor basis entstanden
das heißt ich habe den kanal von den
entdeckern mega lust habe direkt
abonniert hat auch das video von denen
reagiert die haben es auch positiv
aufgenommen also bitte keine kommentare
von wegen ich mache mich über die lustig
oder die über mich das ist alles
wirklich alles nur lustig zu verstehen
so jetzt gibt sie gas evelin falsche
richtung neue level in tempelhof
das spiel ist wirklich schwierig und
spart sich das erst mal gespielt hab ich
überhaupt nicht klargekommen
also
die ersten zwei minuten nicht wie
bereits gesagt das ist alles mit humor
zu verstehen ich wollte da niemanden
herzlich lachen und bin ich ja mal
gespannt wie du die spiele mache ich bin
eine alte frau arbeiten möchte ich ja
firmen leiterin des action bei mir muss
es also evelyn mensch ich kann das auch
überhaupt nicht also um ehrlich zu sein
mein erster konnten auf diesem kanal
waren eigentlich minecraft videos wo ich
irgendwelche sachen gezeigt habe als die
allerdings angefangen habe mannschaft
online zu spielen der andere spieler
online und komplette teams zu spielen
war es na ja da haben mich sehr oft
kommentare bekommen von wegen er in
meiner oma kann besser spielen als du
meine oma hier sehen wir das sind ja
hier das video von denen beherrschen
steife alte hände david nicht mehr so
aber du bist ja noch jung und die
dynamisch würden sich der wusste an ich
habe die mich zum aller ersten mal
gemacht da muss ich ja er will wirklich
recht geben also es stimmt wirklich das
sind natürlich immer noch ältere
menschen die sind nicht mehr so ganz fit
was jetzt diese ganze neue technik
angeht und so das kann natürlich
vollkommen nachvollziehen ist es bei
meiner oma natürlich auch genau so
deswegen ist es natürlich logisch dass
sich die iren konnten beziehungsweise
deren gaming skills nicht zu bewerten
kann wie jetzt beispielsweise von einem
gleichaltrigen aber schauen mal wie sie
auf mich jetzt reagieren und jetzt
wollen wir mal gucken drauf hast du
etwas also wir haben uns folgendes video
von mir ausgesucht und zwar leute ich
bin gespannt mit singenden ist endlich
richtig war warum machst du mal die
statuten ist richtig akkus geschmacks
max mein enkelsohn heißt maximilian
schöner name
sie ist luca kein schöner name bekomme
ich so unfassbar häufig angemerkt sogar
listen stellen ein video sei nicht so
schön reden wie kann man überhaupt so
viel miteinander reden und so schneidet
einander reden es tut mir leid dass es
wirklich irgendwie eine angewohnheit von
mir und die probleme haben sehr sehr
viele leute werden die sich mein content
geben aber ich bin ganz ehrlich wenn ich
die ganze zeit jetzt so langsam reden
würde dann wäre das einfach nicht mehr
ich das wenn nicht mehr authentisch und
ich fände es auch ehrlich gesagt gar
nicht mal so lustig auf laut fuchs
ihr müsst bei auf evelin achten wenn sie
das versucht dann richtig auszusprechen
genau was magst du nicht in diesem video
quasi gemacht haben ist wir haben die
nintendos wii konsole von max genommen
die er zu dem zeitpunkt neu hatte und
haben einfach das nintendo hauseigene
spiel warnte switch gespielt bei diesem
spiel geht es darum dass verschiedene
sportarten dort vorhanden sind wie
beispielsweise wettmelken pingpong
spielen oder auch boxen oder so was
ähnliches und man muss sich gegenüber
stellt die verschiedenen wettbewerbe
gegeneinander bestreiten und wäre das
quasi gewinnt hat gewonnen
übrigens märkte wahrscheinlich auch
schon dass das hier kein typisches
reaction video von mir ist wo ich meine
kämpfen habe und wir uns das video live
zusammen anschauen das liegt einfach
daran in diesem video links die senioren
eingeblendet werden rechts ist mein
video und ich hätte nicht gewusst wo ich
meine face kette hing packen soll
deswegen hab ich mir die datei schon mal
runtergeladen und jeder jetzt quasi so
stück für stück draußen gucken sich ja
nicht an sich aber langsam
jetzt werde ich hier geerntet
ja das problem an der ganzen sache war
dass max und ich kann sie fast die ganze
zeit auf dem bildschirm geguckt haben
weil wir uns einfach daran orientieren
mussten ok läuft die aufnahmen noch
klappt das alles ist es überhaupt
möglich
dass wir das alles irgendwie aufnehmen
und dass das überhaupt funktioniert ja
wir hätten uns vielleicht einfach in die
augen gucken sollen und uns
na gut dann hätten uns halt geschlagen
dass wir auch nicht so cool gewesen und
dann fing im wirklichen leben besser
naja stimmt gebe ich dir recht
tischtennis sein okay ansage von evelin
meine damen und herren er will hat hier
gerade gesagt dass sie das auch noch
schafft also leute wenn ihr möchte dass
ich irgendwann mal vielleicht so damit
max zusammen zu den senioren zocken nach
hause fahre und wir zusammen irgendeinen
video zusammen aufnehmen sondern gewisse
challenge oder so dann lassen alle mal
einen fetten leichter leute und weil ich
das mal bei mikes
das ist so toll dass ich das in letzter
zeit immer mache diese ganzen youtuber
imitieren
michael hat ja leute lasst einfach den
daumen hoch da wenn ihr da wirklich bock
drauf hätte wenn wir mal zusammen video
aufnehmen nur so kann wachs punkt gegen
mich machen unfassbar
schreibt man alle die kommentare max ist
ein schlechtes ich mache mir nicht das
ist ja beeinflussung der
meinungsfreiheit das machen wir nicht wo
sie das war ein witz also vor allem
beeinflussung der meinungsfreiheit
manchmal schlechter spieler dugall so
geht es nicht fair play fair play
nachdem wachsen aufschlag gemacht hat
während ich doch max war dass max hat
kein fairplay gemacht wir haben dieses
spiel
das kann nicht sein
jetzt war die wahrheit ja wir haben 5000
euro dafür bezahlt
[Musik]
das ist ja gute gewinne
das ist der gute gewinne ab sie freut
sich wohl dass max gewonnen hat sagt sie
ja fallen mag hat gewonnen das ist sehr
gute gewinner habe fair gespielt
nicht mag ich nicht elektrisch sondern
man dabei ja ja ja also als nächstes
spiel haben mag es nicht ums wettmelken
rausgesucht das heißt wir müssen quasi
jeder den switches geht nehmen und ihn
quasi so ein bisschen runter holen
runterholen
[Gelächter]
das macht nicht so spaß während wir bei
dem 8
[Gelächter]
da 22 gesagt dass sie lustig sind hey
was sagst du dazu
[Musik]
max es nicht hier fünf jahren geschafft
er war fleißig tolles ergebnis
ihr seid noch so irgendwie noch freude
an solchen dingen stellen dass gerade da
ist wer das für max und mich so das
leben sehr eigene schlechthin so hey wir
haben sind aber beim wettmelken
geschafft
genau das weiß nämlich auch schon das
nächste spiel was max und ich in diesem
video gespielt haben und zwar lust mir
ganz ganz schnell rennen um wer dann am
ende die flagge als erstes quasi die
hand ausgestreckt um eine flagge zudem
hat dann quasi gewonnen genau also auf
meine erklärung kann man eigentlich
scheißen wir können wirklich eigentlich
einfach sagen am strand oder gewonnen
hat was beiden spaß gemacht leute dass
das ist das zitat des tages schreibt
allemal und in die kommentare egal wer
gewonnen hat es hat allen spaß gemacht
dass es leute ich will schaffen wir 70
milliarden kommentare
hatte fast ein holz macht natürlich spaß
an der stelle dann kann ich will ihn für
diese sehr konkrete und eloquent
verfasst
fazit bereicherung zu diesem video danke
er allen wie könnt ihr in beide daumen
geben ja und nicht nur einmal leute da
habt ihr es gehört lasse sich einen like
da sondern zwei das heißt vielleicht
schaffen wir wirklich die
[Musik]
die jungs haben mir auch gefallen muss
ich sagen als uns nächste mal bitte
etwas langsamer reden ja machen wir gar
das angekommen dieses mal reden wir
langsamer seit beide muster ich machte
es richtig auf die natürliche also
wirklich war ihr gefällt mir das ist ja
nicht wahr wie positiv die windigen über
unseren konnte vielleicht kennt man das
auch spielen ja wirklich fein vielleicht
auch konkurrenten bitte bitte geht geht
auf jeden fall macht das also ich finds
mega lustig wenn ich euch beiden händen
wild schweben würde es hat uns spaß
gemacht euch dabei zuzuschauen und
vielleicht spielen wir mal was zusammen
oder machen irgendetwas zusammen genau
freunde wie zu beginn schon gesagt wenn
ihr wirklich bock darauf habe dass wir
uns vielleicht mal in kontakt setzen
oder auch erst mal dass sie dieses video
hier auch sehen lassen einfach mal ein
like da schreibt man die kommentare was
eventuell mit ihm machen könnte dann
fahre ich damit max eventuell mal vorbei
das sagen die jetzt auch noch mal zum
ende des videos hin das ist da überhaupt
die idee das kommt mir jetzt echt stellt
euch mal vor was das für ein publikum
eurer zigtausend 1000 wir treten
zusammen auf dass es doch die idee von
heute das ist die idee von heute meine
damen und herren zeigt es mir irgendwie
ob ihr das wollt und das war es jetzt
auch schon mit deren reaction video auf
mich somit war es das jetzt hier auch
von meinem video meine damen und herren
wie gesagt wenn solch gefallen hat ich
habe schon oft genug gesagt dass ich
jetzt endlich mal schaffen möchte drei
likes auf dem video hinzukriegen ihr
findet hier oben ein smiley eingeblendet
bekommen wir sind heute ein bisschen
anders ihr findet ihr unten 12 die
eingeblendet wenn er darauf stehen
könnte ihm einen kanal kostenlos
abonnieren verpasst keine videos mehr da
unten findet ebenfalls meinen shop
eingeblendet und hier oben ist ein
anderes video verlinkt
also ja klickt man auf den smiley